lucerne est contenue on vit vraiment s'y
faire et ils n auraient pas je suis
vraiment lésés j'aime bien tiens prends
dans mes posts ressentir 6 rebonds alors
5e à 15 h au stade des minimes
ouais c'est un ensemble
tu as hautmont faire à temps faut être
un petit peu plus et payer son opinion
après
et
qui le fait mieux que lui je le fais bon
alors maintenant je voulais dire à se
fiche bien au coeur ouais mais tu sais
qu'un jour je suis un rocker il est
vachement avec le banel sais qu'un jour
j'ai pris la balade avec jacky on a
présenté pas innocent ben merde n'a pas
encore pardonné alors maintenant vais je
voudrais dire que sophie vous risque un
jour de rencontrer sur un plateau de
cinéma
patrick sébastien caron parle de plus en
plus de l'acteur j'ai envie